let's talk about the game for a little
bit let's talk about the game okay let's
talk about the game
when we last saw justin fields
against trevor lawrence in the
semifinals justin fields was phenomenal
right
and i had real questions about whether
or not justin fields would even be able
to play it's not like there's
transparency in college football injury
like there is at the nfl level and i
wasn't paying attention to it we had the
end of the season
we had coaching changes we had playoff
games and justin feels looked fine to me
but it wasn't the same guy that we saw
against clemson and to the extent that
there was any steam out there
building that maybe he could somehow
make the jaguars think twice that went
out the window because for as good as he
was
in the semifinal game he was a
non-factor in the
championship game so he's still number
two at best trevor lawrence is number
one i i think so i
you know again the the the final four
performance against clemson was great
there's no doubt you see
like you see the talent you can see that
the potential everything that's there
even on a night like last night where it
wasn't perfect
but what we saw last night is something
that kind of pops up with justin fields
just every now and then
and it's it's coachable it's you can
clean it up it's not like
oh no i have real concerns about this
guy no
not at all big strong smart you know
looks like a dak prescott out there to
me but but faster
in a lot of ways but you do see every
now and then and we even saw this about
three four weeks ago before they got
into the big ten championship
or even in the big ten championship of
just throws where you go
damn he's too good to miss that throw
you know i think about like
the second series of the game mike i
don't know if you remember you had a
little shallow cross
guy's gonna catch the ball and run for a
touchdown you know they ended up scoring
he made
other great throws to get them down
there but just little
like should be a slam dunk consistent
type throw
is still needs work with justin fields
so there is some things there i think
with
his throwing mechanics uh that could be
fixed and adjusted a little bit you
heard me talk about it the other day
you know there's a little extra movement
in his arm and that's i think something
to watch for as we get ready for the
draft and do all that stuff
well and uh look they had to be perfect
last night in the office of execution
match alabama it was like a tennis match
early on touchdown touchdown touchdown
touchdown
and we were talking before the show when
they were held to a field goal and it
was 21-17 that was it
that that was the moment and then it
just it just went from there next thing
you know is 28 17 then it's 35-17 and
and uh you know they didn't give up they
kept fighting they kept
trying but uh it was just two different
qualities of roster on the field last
night and
and i think that it keeps justin fields
where he is now he may not be number two
now
after seeing what devonta smith did just
in the first half over 200 receiving
yards three touchdowns player of the
game
and he exited early in the third quarter
with a dislocated finger that
uh i think they were having a hell of a
time with i think at one point they were
talking about taking him to the hospital
with his
finger yeah yeah and that's something
now that
that hey you enter the draft and welcome
to
whatever the scouting combine is going
to be this year
but they're going to be making sure that
that finger is fine
because without you know both hands and
all fingers you can't generate
the kinds of numbers we've seen that is
obscene
what this guy has done it's unbelievable
i look at week 10 how in the hell did he
have a game with only three catches and
22 yards that stands out
the other games are phenomenal over the
top and he saved his best for last in
the championship game in one
half oh he had 215 yards 12 catches and
three touchdowns
here here's my thought on this and i
have not studied this carefully
but you know when i see a guy who's of
slight build
who is running around like crazy in the
college level running around
untouched um i think of uh desmond
howard
yeah and i think of what happened to
desmond howard when he came to the nfl
level
and then all of a sudden and if you've
seen the movie the best of times jack
dundee played by robin williams lines up
against the guy known as dr
death and that guy just keeps jamming
him and throwing him down into the
ground and he can never get off the line
of scrimmage
well until the very end of the i don't
want to spoil it if you haven't seen the
best of times i watched it again not
that long ago
it doesn't hold up well it was a
disappointment but
but but yeah yeah i'm sorry 36 years is
the
amount of time that will go on the
spoiler but anyway i
do you have that concern that this guy's
just not big enough to deal with what
he's going to face at the nfl level when
he splits wide
and and there's a guy there ready to to
hit him like he's never been hit before
and keep him from getting into his route
it's going to be the number one thing
probably talk about
with him but you know with the
protection of receivers
and you know the protection of players
over the middle
not hitting defenseless receivers all
those type of things
i don't think it's as much as a worry as
maybe it was 15
20 years ago with that type of guy and
we've seen a lot of
desean jackson hollywood brown type of
guys come in the nfl
and because they're such phenomenal
athletes and so fast
they know how to protect themselves and
stay out of harm's way
so i i don't look at it as an issue
anymore and
i don't think he's the kind of guy
that's going to be making his money
you know run running over the middle a
whole lot anyways as far as
you know in between linebackers and
making those type of catches but
i mean the explosive ability is just
it's off the charts right i i to me the
thing that i'm amazed by with devonte
smith is just
it looks like he's jogging and everybody
else is like behind him running full
speed like
oh i can't and he's like just it doesn't
look like he's breaking a sweat but yet
he's flying because you can just tell
the amount of ground he's chewing up i
mean
he he is definitely a top 10 pick and
now it's going to be like is he a top
five pick for one of these teams that's
got a quarterback that's got a real need
a wide receiver
yeah and and and look and the devante
adams tweet is awesome from now on if
you spell my name make sure it's devonte
cause he's that boy
and uh i i you know what you know what
happens you're gonna have
people in these organizations that
obsess over the measurables and you're
gonna have people say he's too slight he
needs you know
does it will his frame allow him sure
to thicken up like a tyree kill tyree
kill's thick
even though he's not big he's got a
thickness to him that a desean jackson
doesn't have and you're right desean
jackson's had a great career
and he can get off the line of scrimmage
my main concern is getting off the line
of scrimmage but there's all sorts of
motion and stuff
exactly to allow him to get an opening
where he's already got a running start
and you can't keep up with him and and
he if he's going in motion if he goes
into the backfield
there's so many things a creative coach
could do with devante smith at the nfl
level i think that is the thing
that will that will evolve him into the
upper levels of the draft this year he
could go as high as number two
not not necessarily to the jets yeah you
know what if the jets are going to keep
sam darnold
maybe he's your guy at number two well
yeah i mean listen it's all dependent on
you know what position is you know
got a lot of guys that are high level
guys the ranking order of the draft
you know where is there a lot of depth
whereas it depends on how good of
receivers that are going to be in the
draft in the first round conversation
you know if if he's one of maybe only
two or three guys in that conversation
then
yeah he might be in the top five or top
ten like that just because people are
gonna go wait
we gotta get them now and when you look
at teams like the jets and the dolphins
with yes young quarterbacks i mean we
don't know what the jets are gonna do
that makes sense in a lot of ways i mean
the philadelphia eagles sit in the
number
six yeah i mean we talked about they
need a wide receiver definitely
you know so i there's definitely going
to be play for a guy like devonta smith
because
football has become just like a lot of
all the other sports
it's homers and strikeouts that's what
it is it's it's
yeah okay it's all about big plays
and shifting field position and devante
smith is one of those guys in
in a punt return a slant a screen behind
the line of scrimmage he can change the
field position
or just go ahead and flat out score and
that's special game breakers are
are in need more than ever in the nfl
right now
you make a great point though about the
the concentration of
total receivers because why do you burn
a top five pick
on devontae smith if there's a chase
clay pool lurking in round two
right it's almost like with running
backs now with receivers and this gets
back to the old
seven on sevens from the time they're 13
years old
all those quarterbacks throwing passes
plenty of guys running routes and
catching passes
developing and developing and improving
and the next thing you know they're
ready to enter the nfl
and there's too many other positions to
get all the good receivers taken
early teams have different needs there
are great players in all shapes and
sizes
and somehow a guy like a dk metcalf
lingers to the bottom of round two
so that's part of the balance that gets
that gets into that running back
conversation like do we have to use a
top 10 pick on a running pack we can get
a running back anywhere
do we have to use a top five pick on
devontae smith we can get a receiver
that's
you know yeah not as good but
all right and we get two extra draft
picks for trading down and doing it
right i mean that's what you got to
balance
and this other guy's 6'3 and he's 220
and he's got an nfl body already and
this idea of is he going to hold up
sure that's not going to be a factor for
us there's all sorts of
of issues like that that will come up as
they begin the process
of scouring over all of these college
players in a truncated season for a lot
of teams it's gonna be harder than ever
for these scouts to to make good
decisions reliable decisions especially
when you consider
we don't know what the combine is going
to be will there be pro days again
it's going to be very hard to get the
full body of information that scouts
have had
in past years it's going to be a lot
like last year last year may even be
better
in many ways than this year was because
at least last year they had the full
scouting combine before the world turned
upside down
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports